violence has fled up in the West Bank
again and Israelis are taken to the
streets to protest against their own
government on the eve of its 75th
Anniversary Israel is divided like never
before
for almost three months now Israelis
have been taken to the streets in
increasing numbers to demonstrate
against the new government the
protesters want to stop controversial
reforms to the country's Judiciary they
say that if the reforms pass
it will Mark the end of democracy here
the protests have largely been peaceful
but as they've grown in size and
Desperation there have been clashes with
police
opposition leaders have warned that if
they are ignored and if no compromise is
found it could lead to Civil War it's a
dramatic statement designed to capture
the headlines but it does speak to the
strength of feeling and the growing
political divide and the protests in
Israel are happening against a backdrop
of increasing violence in the West Bank
the Israeli military has been carrying
out raids in Palestinian towns and
villages on an almost daily basis to
arrest suspected militants and seize
weapons these incursions often turn
violent already this year 80
Palestinians and 12 Israelis have died
in the violence children have also been
killed on both sides
[Music]
Israel's new government is the most
right-wing in the country's history for
many years the Israeli right has wanted
to limit the power of the cause
nationalists are infuriated that judges
often limit settlement expansion in the
West Bank and the ultra-orthodox want to
introduce laws that conform with their
religious beliefs under the reforms the
government of the day will have a
virtual veto on any new judges appointed
and we'll be able to pass laws
unchallenged with a simple majority of
one but in the Israeli Parliament don't
get knesset but with no written
Constitution a largely ceremonial
president and only one house in the
parliament the Supreme Court is seen as
the only check on government Behavior
remove that and the government could
effectively do what it wants
many Israelis fear the reforms will mean
the end of the liberal democracy that
they've spent 75 years building I want a
free speech I own a free country I want
the same right for every person of every
religion of every nationality they
believe it will erode human rights
women's rights and sexual freedoms
historically Netanyahu has always been a
popular politician is Israel's longest
serving leader we're afraid that we will
become a dictatorship instead of the
Democracy that we have right now you
believe Netanyahu is becoming a dictator
absolutely and if elections were held
again today the opinion polls say that
he wouldn't win there's been criticism
from all sectors of Israeli Society
Orthodox and secular young and old right
wing and left wing even some Israeli
military reservists have gone on strike
the Israeli currency the shekel has
weakened and the usually a political and
much celebrated tech industry has
threatened to pull investment and jobs
from the country International
condemnation of the reforms has been
widespread most significantly from
Israel's closest Ally the US the United
States also remains firmly opposed to
any acts that could trigger more
insecurity including settlement
expansion and inflammatory rhetoric
foreign at the moment Netanyahu seems to
be beholden to the strong right-wing
voices in his Coalition he is currently
on trial for charges of Fraud and
bribery which he denies but his critics
say he is only pushing through the
reforms to get himself out of that trial
the opposition and the Israeli president
have both called for a halt in the
reform so discussions can take place so
far Netanyahu has refused if he were to
pause or water down the reforms he faces
rebellion in his cabinet and possibly
the collapse of the coalition
[Music]
the idea of a two-state solution is
something that foreign diplomats and
some Palestinians still cling to the
reality though is that we are nowhere
near that moment right now the new
Israeli government includes senior
far-right ministers who want to build
more Israeli settlements in the West
Bank and dramatically reduce Palestinian
rights many young Palestinians have lost
hope have few prospects and are fed up
at Israeli raids into their cities so
they are taking up arms to challenge the
Israeli occupy this all leads to Violent
clashes and a seemingly never-ending
spiral of death with politicians on
either side either unwilling or unable
to stop it talk of a new Uprising a
third into fada is growing
Israel is facing a constitutional crisis
if the government pushes ahead with the
reforms and they've showed no sign of
slowing down then they could be
challenged in the very courts that they
seek to weaken should that happen and
the Supreme Court ultimately find them
unlawful then the Attorney General might
be compelled to declare Netanyahu unfit
for office
and the civil service including the
police and the military would have to
decide who it obeys the government or
the courts it could get very nasty